[Aplausos]
[Música]
se le conoce como de lakic and three el
país afortunado
son increíbles playas una rica vida
natural y muchos muchísimos recursos
naturales
así es australia el paraíso del sur y
también del cricket ese deporte
británico tan pausado que hasta paran
para comer y tomar el té australia
amigos de visual política es un país tan
especial tan único que el 80 por ciento
de sus plantas y animales no existen en
ninguna otra parte del mundo fijaros si
aquí todo es raro que de hecho su animal
más característico casi su emblema
nacional el canguro no corre ni trota
sino que salta
en su medio natural no solo es único
también es temible australia tiene más
cosas que puedan matarnos que ningún
otro lugar por ejemplo las 10 serpientes
más venenosas del mundo son de aquí de
australia
no te parece suficiente quieres más
pruebas del hostil que puede llegar a
ser el ecosistema australiano pues bien
atentos a estos cuatro animales la araña
de tela de embudo la medusa cofre el
pulpo de anillos azules y el pez piedra
todos ellos están en australia y son los
más letales de su especie en el mundo
y cuidado porque hay más mucho más
cocodrilos gigantes que llegan a pesar
más de 1500 kilos o tiburones de todos
los tipos y tamaños y si los animales
aún no te parecen suficiente no cantes
victoria hay muchos muchísimos más
peligros naturales de todo tipo porque
australia es una tierra seca calurosa
árida y climatológicamente muy agresiva
sin embargo ninguna de estas cosas ha
impedido ni remotamente que australia se
haya convertido en un sueño para
millones de personas que anhelan un
futuro mejor tampoco es tan raro fijaros
que lugares tan increíble podemos
encontrar esto es lagos
y lo reconozco amigos a mí australia
también me ha cautivado
[Música]
pero ojo no solo hablamos de la gente
corriente en los últimos años que este
país ha convertido también en un imán
para los millonarios para las grandes
fortunas porque para verlo vamos a dejar
a un lado los animales y vamos a hablar
de los negocios
australia un imán para las grandes
fortunas cada día es más fácil moverse
por el mundo hoy podemos llegar
prácticamente a cualquier lugar de forma
rápida y cómoda y además gracias a
internet ya todas las nuevas formas de
comunicación hoy podemos dirigir un
negocio a miles de kilómetros de
distancia fijaros cómo han cambiado las
cosas en relativamente poco tiempo hace
apenas 50 años un viaje en avión entre
londres y sydney estaba repleto de
escalas y no duraba menos de 3 días
hoy este trayecto se puede hacer en
apenas 12 horas en un avión cómodo
seguro y con una pantalla plana para
cada pasajero con cientos de películas
series y música
seguramente cosas así son las que han
hecho que hoy las grandes fortunas sean
más exigentes al fin y al cabo pueden
elegir fácilmente qué sitio prefieren
para vivir sin que esto afecte para nada
a sus negocios hoy los millonarios ya no
se conforman sólo con impuestos
atractivos también quieren vivir en
lugares con calidad de vida buenos
colegios facilidad para hacer negocios y
seguridad ojo tanto física como jurídica
es decir la seguridad que les permite
que sus ahorros estén a salvo de
cualquier déspota o la que les garantiza
que no van a terminar en la cárcel por
llevarse mal con algún político el 64%
de los millonarios chinos están
considerando o están en trámites para
fijar su residencia permanente en otro
país y aquí australia tiene mucho que
ofrecer por un lado es la quinta
economía más libre del mundo en este
país es fácil muy fácil hacer negocio
hay muchas oportunidades la justicia
funciona bien tiene un sistema
financiero muy competitivo y en general
las regulaciones son livianas
por otro lado es uno de los países donde
mejor se vive y donde más servicios de
calidad se pueden encontrar como
hospitales universidades o colegios de
hecho sus grandes ciudades se sitúan año
tras año en los puestos más altos en los
rankings internacionales de calidad de
vida por ejemplo melbourne lleva seis
años consecutivos liderando el ranking
elaborado por the economist sobre las
ciudades donde mejor se vive fijaros qué
maravilla de sitios
[Música]
y por si fuese poco en 2012 el país
aprobó un programa de puertas abiertas
para las grandes fortunas todos aquellos
millonarios que inviertan unos 3
millones y medio de dólares americanos
obtienen la residencia permanente para
los millonarios que no tengan tanta
liquidez hay otro programa que solo
requiere invertir unos 750 mil dólares
en este caso hay algunas restricciones
pero en poco tiempo se puede acceder
también a la residencia permanente
calidad de vida facilidad para hacer
negocios y puertas abiertas sabéis cuál
ha sido el resultado atentos porque es
sorprendente tanto en 2015 como en 2016
australia ha sido el país del mundo al
que más millonarios se han trasladado
más incluso que a eeuu en concreto en
2016 11 mil millonarios se trasladaron a
este lugar y una cifra increíble para un
país cuya población no llega a los 25
millones de habitantes aproximadamente
la mitad de españa y la verdad puede que
este sea el mejor ejemplo de la
locomotora imparable que es hoy la
economía australiana
y la mejor versión de eeuu cuando llegas
a australia tienes la sensación de haber
llegado a una versión mejorada de eeuu
me explico en general las ciudades y los
modelos de sociedad de ambos países son
relativamente similares
australia por tener tiene incluso su
propia washington es decir una capital
levantada por y para el poder político
porque muchas veces se olvida pero la
capital de australia no es sídney ni es
melbourne es canberra
[Música]
la verdad es que los propios
australianos podrían pasar a primera
vista por estadounidenses si no fuese
porque conducen por la izquierda beben
té y adornan los espacios públicos con
estatuas de la reina victoria si
recordad que australia formalmente es
una monarquía y su actual reina es
isabel segundo
pues bien la cuestión es que a pesar de
las similitudes a usted le es un país
más seguro más limpio más moderno más
cosmopolita más próspero e incluso los
australianos son mayoritariamente más
ricos que los estadounidenses cuando los
australianos visitan los eeuu ven un
país en declive los australianos ven los
malos aeropuertos las infraestructuras
los pobres los mendigos ahora ya sabéis
por qué digo lo de versión mejorada por
lo general en los medios de comunicación
se habla poco de australia pero este
país lleva atentos 26 años sin conocer
lo que es una crisis la última vez que
el país entró en recesión
gorbachov ocupaba el poder en la unión
soviética no está mal verdad quiero
poner tierra
el diputado ayudáis el vaquerito
en mi crisis financiera ni crisis de las
puntocom ni de las materias primas de
desempleo nada de nada el resultado con
tan sólo 24 millones de habitantes su
economía ya es tan grande como la de
toda rusia
[Música]
y además es un caso curioso del que nos
conviene tomar nota austral es un país
muy dependiente de las materias primas
que suponen por ejemplo más de la mitad
de todas sus exportaciones en 2019
australia superará a qatar como mayor
exportador mundial de gas natural
licuado pues bien cuando el precio de
las materias primas se vino abajo todo
parecía apuntar a que australia seguiría
el camino de economías en crisis como
rusia a brasil-ecuador arabia saudita
vamos que los tiempos de alegrías
llegarían a su fin sin embargo nada de
esto ocurrió aquí a diferencia de
prácticamente el resto de países
productores la crisis de las materias
primas pasó sin pena ni gloria pero que
hace que este país parezca casi
invulnerable a cualquier crisis vayamos
a verlo
el secreto del éxito
a los que nos seguís regularmente ya
sabéis que el visual polític solemos
decir eso de buenas políticas buenos
resultados pues eso es precisamente lo
que ha hecho australia durante las
últimas décadas reformas para mejorar
los cambios han sido muchos así que
vamos a enumerar solo los más
importantes en primer lugar sus
gobiernos apostaron por abrir la
economía al comercio internacional
eliminando la mayor parte de aranceles
hoy el país es un firme defensor de los
acuerdos de libre comercio
[Música]
en segundo lugar a principios de los 90
el gobierno laborista de paul keating
puso definitivamente en marcha un modelo
de pensiones conocido como
superannuation que está basado en la
capitalización un modelo bastante
similar al de chile aunque desde mi
punto de vista bastante mejor por
funcionar con más libertad el resultado
ha sido impresionante el programa ha
permitido generar grandes cantidades de
ahorros que han sido invertidas en la
economía productiva
[Música]
además todo ese inmenso volumen de
ahorros ha impulsado la industria
financiera por ejemplo australia es ya
uno de los mercados más importantes de
fondos de inversión y no sólo eso
australia líder al crecimiento mundial
en tecnología financiera en tercer lugar
muy importante también en 1995 se lanzó
la política nacional de competencia con
el fin de reducir el intervencionismo
público en muchos sectores
este programa consiguió eliminar atentos
casi dos mil normas y leyes que
restringían la competencia además se
puso en marcha un ambicioso plan de
privatizaciones y la eliminación de
monopolios públicos por ejemplo cuántas
que os prometo es mía aerolínea favorita
si tenéis la oportunidad no lo penséis
cuantas
1 2 3 y junto a todo ello estabilidad
presupuestaria flexibilidad laboral
etcétera etcétera
el resultado 25 años sin recesión es
pleno empleo en la economía un salario
medio de más de 5 mil dólares al mes y
muchísima inversión extranjera no está
mal verdad ahora ya podemos saber que
cuando un gobierno culpa de la crisis a
los precios de las materias primas es
porque sencillamente no ha hecho los de
verdad que no se me olvide en los
últimos tiempos
australia está cuajando muy buenas
relaciones con israel un país al que le
acaba de tocar la lotería de los
recursos naturales
si quieres descubrir cómo israel está a
punto de convertirse en toda una
potencia energética no te pierdas este
vídeo donde te lo contamos con todo
detalle las implicaciones en oriente
medio pueden ser enormes bueno y tú como
ves las cosas
acaso sueñas como hago yo con pasar una
temporada recorriendo este fabuloso país
crees que australia será el nuevo eeuu
del siglo 21 no dudes en dejarnos tu
opinión en los comentarios nos ayuda a
muchos a saber cómo veis las cosas y
además siempre
debate si este vídeo te ha resultado
interesante no dudes en darle a like y
por supuesto no te olvides de
suscribirte a visual polític pulsando
aquí para estar al tanto de todos
nuestros nuevos vídeos pronto hablaremos
más australia un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]